who your favorites what stuck out for
you for me I think the teacher was one
of my favorites I have been the teacher
in Louisville the one who said that he
has the kids start with a mantra before
he opens the class of I'm not my
neighborhood I've got my mother and I'm
not my father
yeah and actually that ties into one of
the questions because he talks about
America being a land of opportunity but
he says sometimes some opportunities are
swayed more in favor toward others than
then some of the children that he was
dealing with yeah what are your thoughts
on that I mean do you feel that the way
things are now it's almost similar to
the British class system where there's
less mobility you know okay there are
clearly more privilege situations into
which one can be born or or find
yourself living in and clearly there is
more opportunity for others according to
those things those aspects however
personally I mean oh you know my dad's
not Kenneth Branagh and my mum's not
Emma Thompson and I'm an actor you know
and I'm sort of doing all right in these
Hollywood Hills and stuff and my dad was
a chef and my mum was the secretary
basically and lived in little small
towns in England at the end of the
cul-de-sac with you know Tupperware
parties happening in 1977 thinking is
this it does it okay interesting and I
think it's easy for us at anytime to
sort of rest in a story that we create
as individuals or as a neighborhood or
as a city or as a society or a country
or whatever and just say well this is my
life and so it's not fair for me and you
it's alright for those people on the
other side of the tracks and I think I
mean every day is a bit of a miracle
isn't it and I just think that if we
think more about what is possible and we
spend more time thinking about what we
have therefore and then be grateful
about that and therefore create a more
positive sort of energy about ourselves
because oh I've got the arms and legs
that's fantastic pretty good day
actually I haven't got any nasty disease
that's all right you know I wish I had a
bigger this or a better that or more of
this but you know what in the meantime
it's alright I'm quite happy I'm
fortunate I'm breathing I'm living I'm
seeing this whole like miraculous thing
that's happening around me and then you
sort of feel a bit better and then I
think there's a great propensity for
sort of more positive things to come
into your life as a result of just
feeling better
whereas sort of sitting inside a story
and going our you know my life of this
and nothing's gonna happen to me and you
know the whole life for I should be so
lucky and all that sort of stuff you
know little declarations and statements
that we say all the time self limitation
you know you look at that and you think
well now that's gonna happen because
you're thinking it and that's your
vibration now you know I'd only had two
sort of stars and moons about it but I
do think that what you you you create
what you think it's kind of what you
create cuz you're thinking it so you're
like well nothing's gonna happen
nothing Goods can wrap around dear me
right well that's that then nothing
Goods gonna happen round here anything
good can happen anywhere
you know we tell ourselves that you know
or nothing Goods gonna happen round here
but it does happen good things do happen
and you know when Kevin the teacher
talks about you know some there's more
opportunity for others than there are
for others
yeah sure there there are you could be
born into certain situations where that
can be the case but there's no reason
why you know you can't just step outside
of the story that's going on around you
whether it's in you in your mind or in
your family or in your neighborhood your
city in just go you know what I'm
stepping out of this there's something
better miracles happened to be there and
I'm gonna be one of them you know and I
remember a very successful basketball
player saying something like that to me
once he said he just looked around
you know I'm not doing this I'm not I'm
I'm stepping outside of this story and
he became very successful and I believe
that if you believe it anything can
happen but in but in the meantime just
think to yourself we know what it's all
right in the meantime to have got me
hands me on whatever makes me happy is
is going on I've got that so thank you
cheers appreciate it very much but I
wouldn't mind a bit of that life would
be nicely looking at a bit of that and I
could be a service as well and then you
do that and then um you feel better and
then you might make a few other people
feel better as well along the way so you
know anything's possible isn't it if you
want it to be one other interview that I
thought was you know not Billy Graham or
whatever much no no no I get it because
a lot of you I I was reading something
on Quora the other day that so much bad
stuff happens sometimes when you're on a
downturn and then you add alcohol to
that whole thing and then the whole
thing goes up and people were talking
about losing their jobs and how it was
like a spiral of negativity and and I do
see that it's just hard to see it when
you're in that moment I get it it is
hard you know
and I'm not saying it's easy to just
sort of go no I I know when I first came
to Los Angeles Bureau it's very
difficult it's very competitive and all
the rest of it and I was thinking well I
just happen to be here because of
circumstance that's like well you know
yeah okay it's competitive and difficult
and what have you
of course but anyway I'm here now so
should we you know see what we're going
always that Beverly Hills you know just
enjoy the experience you know I mean
just see what there's always something
good to experience around you you know
something good somewhere let's just look
at that
you